alright thanks everybody yeah bring your
B now let's see there we go yeah so if
you look on the schedule it says that
I'm Dana Bauer that's my other identity
I'll be Kyle today Dana is speaking
tomorrow she wasn't feeling well and
I'll give a plug for a talk later right
so as I said Kyle RGB kereke on twitter
and i worked at Rackspace within the
developer experience group and so we we
build tools to help developers and then
we try to support people with using our
cloud and our services and everything
else and then donate time and resources
as much as we can to open source
projects with which we're passionate and
that we want to see grow and as part of
that I end up working on ipython and
working on the Jupiter project and some
of that involves hosted things we've
done like right now we run the the
notebook viewer and temporary notebook
system and the try Jupiter stuff and if
you saw the nature article on a Python
then then that's what else were running
right and so I'm guessing a lot of
people in here no I Python like who in
here uses the ipython notebook or
console or any of that I was trying to
find that somebody didn't raise a hand
it's always bad to do it that way
because I'm like singling someone out
but I still wanted to see who they were
right but but what what languages do you
work in like I did anybody what
languages do you use our Python Fortran
definitely Scala right so clearly
everyone here at PI data is using Python
I'm kidding there's there's lots of
languages all right and with that comes
like with the overall ipython
architecture all bunch of kernels for
different languages so I have 28 here I
couldn't get all of them to fit i think
there's 32 right Julia Haskell F sharp
JavaScript I think there's like four
different JavaScript kernels they're all
over the place right and at the barre at
the core of it we're doing them some
amount of like for a Python terminal
execution standard in San burnout and
communicating back over a defined JSON
protocol over 0 mq back to a kernel your
messages reality you're just getting
this interactive experience with your
rifle and your data and and everything
else with the code right and then people
write these different kernels to express
how to work with their language whether
it's it's scholar Julia or anything else
right but but what's what's in the name
so as people use the ipython notebook
and they're working in Julia are they go
what about us this is not all Python
right like up here on the on the num
focus banner there's our open sigh and
Julia it's not all Python right and
people are going to work across a bunch
of different languages um so we had to
come up with a different name and if you
think naming things is hard you should
try renaming things I I think it took us
six months to pick a new name and there
were a lot of bad ones this was the
least bad one um part of what's coming
up here is is and that's currently going
on and if you look across our repos
right now as the ravenous big split and
it's not a split of like fracture
tension amongst the community it's a
split of hey let's put all the language
agnostic stuff into its own separate
area let's make Jupiter for the notebook
console the notebook viewer a lot of
those core pieces that aren't about
Python itself and are just about
interactive computing
right so I said it's not a fork I tried
to gather together a whole bunch of the
new projects and put them all in one
place and I couldn't get them all to fit
and I gave up there are many many pages
and the same goes for ipython right and
so that the dominant piece that we have
to now talk about is Jupiter right so
that's language agnostic components a
multi-user system and so we're talking
about the Jupiter hub where people can
all log and share the same resources
same lab environment there's the
temporary notebook system and then we
want to expose a lot of the building
blocks for building your own stuff on
top of the Colonel's themselves right
and we can get into new projects and
explorations the predominant like
product if you will that people are
using right now is that is the notebook
server right you you come up to the
browser or you work with your data and
everything else and you've got this
common file format that works across you
know if you want to share with a
colleague the notebook that you've been
working on right that communicates back
with a colonel it provides the plots
that you're doing it gives you
javascript interaction and all those
bits all right so these common formats
keep us free and unencumbered all right
you've got this notebook that you can
stick in diversion control but you can
convert to PDF or HTML or just post to
the web and have somebody else render it
through the notebook viewer right and
and there are news news articles that
are being written that are backed by
notebooks the people are writing whole
books and all of that all right and so
the hard part here is no where where do
we go like namespace wise to make sure
that we're language agnostic so in the
future you'll be writing Jupiter
notebook to get to your main notebook
server right and so so one of these new
things that we're working on is Jupiter
hub let's see if this will play maybe oh
my gosh I don't know how to keynote I
guess keynote in a keynote
we're gonna try something different
okay maybe I won't okay all right so
Jupiter hub is a multi-user environment
you can set up for example github Oh off
at the very front to log into a notebook
serve to a notebook set up across many
users currently at Berkeley there's a
computational models class where there's
more than 220 students that are all
logging into the same system they can
work do their homework and everything
gets graded out of that same stuff and
and at the end of the day they don't
have to deal with any installation these
are psychology students there are
students from computer science and
whatnot but at the same time like they
don't want to get everyone doing the
installation right great I mean we have
great tools within our landscape to do
installation of those components so like
I certainly go to tutorials and have
everybody just use anaconda like it
solves all the troubles like who and
here's using anaconda currently that's
again most of the room right and then
beyond the note the notebook there's
there's interactive widgets ways that we
can interact with JavaScript to I still
know how to play us play I'd give oh
it's playing there but not oh okay you
can see the animation i can write so I
wrote this custom widget to put together
to analyze a binary stream like shifted
to different widths or look at like an
entire file and so I'm looking across
what user been awk here right and so I
get these great environments to work
with these and I want JavaScript that's
going to work across our or Python or
whatever right the same stuff is
therefore for bouquet like that we just
get this environment that we can
interact with everything so
there we go so recently it was just just
a couple days ago y hat put up this open
source package called rodeo that lets
you work in an editor and have a console
at the bottom and show your data frames
in the corner and the files that you're
working with all in one environment but
what's backing that is ipython they're
using the same kernels but to build an
IDE that's kind of like our studio right
these components are out there and
useful like and now that they're being
broken into smaller blocks you can think
about like what what kind of experience
do I expect to get out of out of the
Colonel's like what what if I could just
demand a kernel on the fly that I can do
execution on like what if I want you
know 40 cores what if I need 20 cores
right it should just be about how do I
get more computational resources and
then how do I have one environment to
work in and so as I was saying dana has
a talk tomorrow on death and open data
it's conquering the fear of open
sourcing data that'll be tomorrow at 220
p.m. and I know every time I come to a
conference everyone has questions about
ipython in Jupiter so I wanted to make
sure that I took time to answer
questions
you